[Musik]
am 11 dezember steht die Sendung Sport
am Sonntag im ORF-Zentrum ganz im
Zeichen der Spendenaktion Licht ins
Dunkel an den spendentelefonen nehmen an
diesem Abend neben 15 Garde Soldaten
auch 10 Heeres Leistungssportler Platz
um Gebote für die zu ersteigernden
Objekte entgegenzunehmen
in einer Suite in fünf Sterne Hotel
Wellness Resort Alpenrose am Achensee
Kollegen mehr oder weniger
die Weihnachtsstimmung zu lassen und ich
glaube dass
heute Abend werden
freien Tag unseres Wochenende
ja ich finde das ist schön ist dass man
eben im Rahmen von unserem
grundverdienst und im
Rahmen unserer präsentationsaufgabe bei
der Garde auch bei so einer also was
besonderem Licht ins Dunkel mitmachen
kann weil es nicht wirklich ernst
alltäglich und das hat er nicht jeder
Idee war gerade ich finde das eigentlich
ziemlich schön dass man damit unsere
Arbeit am Wochenende Leute helfen können
und für uns ist ja immerhin nicht so
große Sache aber ich glaube wir können
einen anderen Leuten damit mehr helfen
es macht wirklich Spaß wir waren ja
vorher auch schon in den Seelen bei der
50 Jahresfeier vom Licht ins Dunkel und
wer noch weiter das
bis zum grünen Abschluss den 24 Dezember
weitermachen ist ein super Projekt um
andere Menschen zu helfen
überhaupt eine Chance hat das zu machen
[Musik]
ich betreue diese positionsleiterin
mittlerweile seit ich fast zehn Jahren
und es macht unheimlich viel Spaß und
die Kooperation mit dem bundesheeren
sehr gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]